today I have a special guest on the
channel welcome to the show Sterling
Cooper I am a retired award-winning I
also used to work as a high class
companion sex was always I guess a bit
Taboo in my family my job was to kind of
be that perfect fantasy of like the the
combination between like a gentleman
it's lonely for like wealthy women it's
incredibly lonely the guys who you would
consider to be like quote unquote
players are actually just men who are
very good at manipulation like that's
that's really her only power is
emotional manipulation in some I'm like
the dude who come who comes in and like
hangs another dude's wife in front of
him I have a list of girls that I would
not would I would I refuse to shoot with
I had directors and companies I refuse
to shoot with I had types of scenes I
would refuse to do and every guy in girl
industry has that and your agent
respects that and he doesn't book you
work violates your no list like the
average guy today has seen more naked
women than like genas Khan would have
seen in his
[Music]
lifetime what up guys welcome to the sit
down today I have a special guest on the
channel welcome to the show Sterling
Cooper it's good to be back so Sterling
you've been on the show a couple times
you're regular on our panel shows um why
don't you introduce yourself to the
people at home that do not know your
background so I am a retired
award-winning star okay I also used to
work as a high class male companion
servicing wealthy business ladies shall
we say
and PR of that I was also in the swinger
scene as a single guy as what you would
call a bull in that scene and now I've
given up that life of degeneracy and I
kind of pull on that experience of
Performing under pressure in sexual
scenarios and I help guys they help just
the average dude to overcome things like
performance anxiety erectile dysfunction
which a big one premature ejaculation I
teach them how to please their woman
teach them how to get them off and yeah
because of that I'm able to help men
women couples all over the world and
actually you know contribute to society
in a positive way now so tell me um you
you said you have siblings I do I've got
an older brother and an older sister
okay how do and you're from Australia
originally how does one go from nice
wholesome family in
Australia to swinger escort
and it's a very good question uh you
know because I just I wouldn't it's even
talking to you like I don't even get
that vibe from you I wouldn't even I
like would never have guessed if I
didn't know yeah yeah well that's good
thank you yeah I like to think I present
a somewhat classy yeah no seriously how
did it happen I guess it was
um sex was always I guess a
bit until I'd left home what religion
Christian Catholic like uh we didn't
really have a religion in our house okay
but my mom had a Bible by her bed every
day of her life okay so te I think
technically I think technically we're
we're some kind of protestant um dad's
family was Catholic Irish background
okay but his dad changed to he Methodist
that's what he was Methodist which is
some kind of protest I don't know I
don't have a clue what all that means to
be honest but yeah Tech technically
Christian but not really Christian okay
not practicing at all so you never saw
them kiss or anything yeah like the the
this the most intimate I ever saw my
parents was like a kiss on the cheek so
where did this like where did it come
from you know what's funny I so I took
my dad on like a tour of America last
year yeah and we got to do like a lot of
bonding and like just basically just me
getting him drunk and having him tell me
stories and stuff and I realized where
it came
from dad was a bit of a dog in in back
in the day okay so I'm like it because
it was for me it was like a light bulb
going off
why am I this complete pervert when I
came from this like super wholesome like
normal regular family like Ah that's
where it comes from so how old were you
when you
started like all of that stuff probably
started mid 20s mid 20s yeah okay mid
20s what was being an escort like like I
didn't even know women got escorts yeah
but it's women who are it's typically
women who are mid-30s career women okay
um
have a hard time finding love or have a
I'd say have a hard time
finding the kind of guy they want to be
with MH settling down with them MH
because the guy they want to be with is
chasing tale of like the 18 19 20y old
Secretary MH you know what I'm saying MH
so my job was really to be that guy to
be that classy gentleman that whine and
dine them and and you know that's kind
of like my job was to kind of be that
perfect fantasy of like the the
combination between like a gentleman but
still quite uh sexually deviate behind
closed doors like to give them that
fantasy they wanted so it was this
really it was a really interesting
Learning lesson into like female
psychology for me what type of jobs did
these chicks do was it like lawyer I'm
thinking of like lawyers yeah like any
any any like white color six figure job
okay like lawyers HR actually had a
couple cops oddly enough really yeah
actually once here in Britain I had a
had a British police officer she was uh
yeah just look I guess yeah looking to
lose that Authority okay in a way um had
my best client was this like
multi-millionaire Chinese lady who ran
like a uh it was like a Plastics
Manufacturing Company back in China wow
super super interesting and that was
that was one of the most interesting
experience I got so she used to fly me
out to New Zealand on skiing trips M
just we'd spend the week
together and it was actually kind
of it wasn't she wasn't sad but the
story was a bit tearful because she told
me that her whole
family every time they interacted with
her CU she was the wealthiest one of her
family decam millionaire whole time
anytime anyone in her family interacted
with her all they wanted from her was
money trying to get money from her she
couldn't she was technically married
back in China um he was some kind of
like high level uh musician I don't want
to dox anybody um but it wasn't it was a
marriage of to save face it wasn't a
marriage of Love uh they'd never had sex
they didn't they didn't have they' never
I think they they' done it they
consumated it maybe once or twice but it
wasn't a relationship that had sex so he
was still in China and she was living in
Melbourne wow and the only person in so
so because she's married on paper she
can't be seen dating anybody right she
can't she can't go out and meet you know
a guy through one of her friends or
anything like that so she's screwed
there she can't confide in any of her
family members because all they want is
money from her the only person she could
confide in was her niece and her niece
wanted to be a chef her niece she she
loved food and so she would spoil her
niece by taking her to like five star
restaurants all the time and it was the
way of bonding MH and that but that as
she was telling me that story I was like
man like it's lonely for like wealthy
women yeah it's incredibly lonely CU
they do they do not have an easy time
finding a guy who is like kind of going
to be on their level and is going to
yeah be like intimate and passionate
with them it's really it was a really
eyee opening experience that one did you
ever have women that were married all
the time really the so they would they
were like so I know you just said her
but like in like actual marriages where
it wasn't just a face Y and why did they
tell you that they hired
you they never really would tell me why
they hired me like verbatim like I hired
you for this it was but it was more of a
case of them they would talk about the
problems they had with their husband how
the marriage was sexless um how the
passion had gone and things like this do
do you find that sexless marriages are
typically the choice of the woman or the
guy that's a tough one you have to be an
expert in that topic what contributes to
that yeah I think for the well the the
clients I was seeing I think were
probably like an exception to the rule
yeah uh based upon what I hear from guys
who study my material like on my YouTube
my my email list all that sort of stuff
I'd say it's more the case of the woman
like not being she's her lust isn't
inspired by her man anymore because he's
kind of taken a backseat he's kind of
coasting through the relationship like
when you have the the like the honeymoon
phase at the beginning of a relationship
both of you want to tear your clothes
off it's great you know and that energy
comes from both sides but eventually
guys will get kind of complacent and
fall into a habit and a routine and
that's when you kind of stop seducing
each other right CU if if you're not the
kind of guy who's going to inspire that
lust out of her in the first place well
she's going to be less sexual towards
you he's going to try less not as hard
and it's it's going to slowly degrade to
nothing so I don't I it sounds bit harsh
just trying to put all the burden of
responsibility on the guy MH but that's
life as a guy I think and so I would say
it's for the most part it's down to the
guy to make sure that stays there now if
she's getting fat and not you know no
I'm serious but if she's you know
getting out of shape or whatever okay
well he has to let's say inspire a
little bit of jealousy in her okay to
make sure that she stays on track mhm
cuz otherwi like if she's complacent and
she'll get complacent when she thinks
that her man has no sexual options at
all when he's not a guy who women want
to flirt with or he gets attention from
women well she ain't going to really put
any why does she got to put any effort
in right she's getting she's getting her
into the into the bargain met right yeah
house is paid for mortgage paid for she
can you know do her things or whatever
like it's a balance that both both sides
need to have incentive for it to work do
you think it's possible to avoid like I
don't know relationships getting boring
over time you know CU because life is
it's so long like if you want to
actually have a 20 30 40 50 year
marriage which it's rare nowadays
anyways but let's say that's your goal
is it even possible to avoid things
getting
boring I would say
that borom isn't like this this thing
you need that you should be super
worried about it's like kind of more of
a lack of like fillment between the two
of you like and I think I think that's
comes I'm I'm talking as a guy who's not
who doesn't have a family doesn't have a
wife so take whatever I'm saying here
was a grain assault obviously it's just
my opinion and it's my opinion based
upon what I've seen from like friends
relationship stuff you yeah you've
probably dealt with more women than like
any the averaged guy yeah well it's
funny I'll hear these guys come and say
I've been married 10 years 15 years and
I'm like well that's not 50 you know
what I mean and I I almost think like
sometimes the players have a little bit
respectfully but like have a little bit
more of like uh a grasp on female nature
and nor know more about women because
they've dealt with more women than the
average married man typically yes yeah
like the average Mar that Mar that
married man knows his wife yeah inside
and out yeah well you do see you you
still will see a lot of guys in
long-term relationships long like
longterm marriages who've who've kind of
been um hand peeed right they've been
[__] whipped or whatever so that that
fundamentally tells me that he doesn't
actually understand female nature if the
dynamic is off in that relationship well
he probably would have been I'm not that
I'm trying to encourage little but he
probably would have been better sort of
sewing his oats a bit when he was
younger to kind of learn a bit of the
darker side of female nature rather than
going into a long-term relationship
naively and you know eventually let's
not say maybe he's not necessarily
getting taken advantage of but he's
certainly not wearing the pants in the
relationship and I don't think she's
happy if he if she's wearing the pants I
think no woman's happy in that
relationship really they'll get
resentful right and that's eventually
when they'll hire a guy like me or cheat
on on him with a guy like me and it's
it's not a good situation for anyone so
I'd much rather the dude be wearing the
pants and the dude be stepping up and at
least understanding his role in that
Dynamic so what is the Dark Side of
female nature cool so the the light side
of female nature is the nurturing kind
of mother motherly aspect and the well
the nurturing aspect towards your
partner and your kids I'd say right and
the dark side is the manipulation okay
you can say the same thing for men right
for men the the light side of the man is
protecting and providing the dark side
is violence right we we're all perfectly
aware that men are more violent than
women it's not a surprise to anyone oh I
disagree you think women are more
violent think women are more violent I
think men are well I think men are far
better at violence corre better way
better at violence I when I the reason I
think that women are more violent is
because we're more likely to kill the
infants than the elderly men usually
have a reason for killing I didn't say
it's always a good reason but I think
the vi more violent one kills the
innocent that's my might be right there
yes but let's just say that that's still
like men are still better at that yes
men are better at violence and women are
better at manipulation yes way better at
manipulation to men that's ironically
the guys who you would consider to be
like quote unquote players MH are
actually just men who are very good at
manipulation okay they're men who have
mastered the female weapon okay right so
what when I say manipulation I mean
things like emotional
coercion right okay like which is really
all a woman has like that's that's
really her only Power is emotional
manipulation in some way now she can she
can man manipulate and I'm using the
term manipulate Loosely here right but
she can manipulate a man in a positive
way by like OG GE maybe cooking him
dinner having like a warm like roast
dinner waiting on the table when he gets
home that's like I'm falling in love
with that woman that's that's still
emotional manipulation but it's done in
a positive way in a positive context
okay the negative emotional side the
negative manipulative side of that is
like the nagging like the the belittling
him the emasculating him in front of
other people right to try and get him to
do a certain thing that's kind of the
more manipulative the darker side of
that I'd say but it's women are women
have to use that the same way the same
way that a baby has to cry to get What
It Wants can't do anything else MH well
not it can't it can't go grab like the
bottling milk for itself yeah has to cry
to let you know that it needs something
right and women cannot get what they
want in the world through physical Force
men can men have been using violence
since the dawn of time to get what they
want out of the world right okay I want
that pile of gold I'm going to club that
guy over the head and take it right cool
but women can't do that so what do they
have to do they have to use the to the
one tool they have which is really
emotional manipulation and it's
primarily emotional manipulation of men
and again I'm not saying it's a bad
thing I'm just saying it is you know
that's just the nature of the Beast you
know it's tiger Got Stripes and you said
that men um basically that our players
have mastered the art of emotional
manipulation or manipulation of to some
degree okay or they able or at least
they're able to recognize when a woman
is trying to emotionally manipulate them
okay so they resistant to it in a way
okay yeah can I have an
example like of a common one maybe and
like how a guy that is a player would I
don't know avoid it or deal with it he's
okay he's a he's a decent example a
woman uh a woman trying to start an
argument with you okay so she maybe
she's maybe she's like oh why didn't you
call me yesterday let's use that as an
example why didn't you call me yesterday
well that's her her provoc you with like
with an argument to try and get you to
give her more
attention oh so you'll argue back and
forth and she's getting what she wants
she's getting attention right okay well
well a guy who's experienced with women
will recognize that he also recognizes
that's not really Behavior he likes to
encourage right so if she's trying to
argue with me like basically I don't
reply like okay put the phone down and I
wait wait for her to get back into a
good mood and then and then then when
she's being lovely is when I'm going to
show my affection yeah but when she's
not being lovely and she's being a bit
annoying I'm not going to shower her
with affection it's it's not that
complicated but that's a that's a pretty
common example I'd say have you ever
heard the phrase to treat your woman
like a child I haven't heard a phrase I
that before like but uh I've heard I've
heard that reminds me of like when you
kids like when they have a temper
tantrum you have to ignore them well one
of the one of the best selling uh female
self- Health books I believe right now
is something along the lines of like how
to train your man like a dog really yeah
someone showed me this recently that's
probably not the ex I thought the one
was why men love [__] that might be
the one that might that might be the one
yeah yeah there is also one there is
also a book about like how to train your
man like a dog something like this okay
but it's like okay is that that's that's
just as bad oh yeah of a statement you
know what I'm saying well I it's like
that stuff I mean the way I look at it
is like we don't even like the guys that
stuff works on so it's like you're kind
of screwing yourself yep because you're
never you're never going to like a guy
that's getting onto your program so it's
like these girls will bring out these
books and on the outside like let's say
Jada like 20 years ago said this is how
I bagged Will Smith right because she
they were like the couple of everyone
loved you remember this everyone loved
Will and Jada like 10 15 years ago I
don't really I don't really give a [__]
about celebrity stuff but okay but it
you can just take I will take your take
my word but it's like but she doesn't
even like him yeah and it's very clear
she doesn't even like him because he's
the type of guy that that stuff would
work on mentally disrespectful towards
him yeah yeah I he's he's been a
fantastic example for the average guy I
think to like of what what to look out
for yeah like obviously in love with her
her ex to pack whatever that was right
constantly talks about him and brings
him up like all the time nonstop so
disrespectful did you see that her
daughter cried talking about
Tupac nobody did yeah yeah
yeah I think she wrote a letter to Tupac
or something yeah his daughter what
imagine she never met him yeah it was
just based off of what the yeah oh my
God I'm shocked that one of Will's kids
isn't called Tupac yeah like I'm shocked
one of his sons isn't called isn't that
a common thing where like guys will find
out that their kid is named after a
woman's ex-boyfriend yeah I heard that
so that's why that's why the man the man
should name the kid oh oh that's true
because the man's gonna name the kids
after like
ancestors like siblings like ancient
Heroes like Heracles or something you're
going to give him a cool name not going
to call him like nickname him after Chad
or or his his ex Stacy or some [__] that
ain't G to happen yeah what was okay so
what was being a swinger like you had
like a girlfriend you would do that with
no so I was what you would call a bull
is the technical term so I'm I'm like
the dude who come who comes in and like
bangs another dude's wife in front of
him
wow they just they sign up for that very
oh my god I've I've not been putting
this energy out into the universe
deliber to to be fair deliberately in
the last two weeks I've in my DMs I've
had about five different proposals from
married women asking or sliding in my
DMs like and their profile photo is like
them with their husband okay cuz I
always thought of swingers was like
parties or something that's that that is
another big part of it yeah okay but you
did it so they would how would they find
I would go to parties and stuff and I
would also get invited to like yeah a
couple's house and he would sit in the
corner and watch while did he enjoy that
they always enjoy themselves yeah they
they they fetish they fetishize it
yeah like actually or is he just saying
that very often it's the dude's idea to
get another dude into to bang his
wife very very of like what is the
psychology behind that I good question
it's a very good question I
uh I don't I wouldn't personally I'm not
into that yeah like being on that end of
the
equation how it's all like sexual
fantasies and Kinks
MH they to me at least they seem to
be derived from just an exposure to more
and more like perverse or different
things mhm like for example I don't
think anyone
starts like their life off with like the
of being a [__] right it has to be
something that that
is built on after like years of
consuming like graphic material I can't
I honestly can't think of another way
for that to like manifest oh I don't see
there's no no biological it's like a
deviation because
of consumption not mean not just that
fetish but I think I think basically all
fetishes and Kinks have to be to a
degree with the with the one exception
I'll probably make to that that rule
is General
BDSM like more more specifically like
the Dom sub dynamic because I think that
is fundamentally more in line with like
our actual biological roles as men and
women right so that that at least makes
sense in the sense like okay why would a
a woman wanting to be like tied up and
spanked kind of makes sense from like
the biological perspective like men are
stronger than women and thus they
fantasize about stronger men right
but other things like yeah like leather
fetishes like cockold fetishes all this
kind of stuff it's I I I at least have
not come across any other way of kind of
explaining their Origins MH and I'm and
I'm interested in this stuff yeah I'm
trying to learn as much as I can about
it but uh yeah my my that's my current
hypothesis what are you I'm going to
show you something I want to get your
take on this video so tell me what you
have you seen have you seen the Adam 22
I'm kind of familiar with what's going
on to a degree all right so Adam 22
loaned his wife out for a only fans
video right he his wife um had sex with
um I think his name is Jason love yeah
yeah who's like I guess he's a
big yeah and so now this is the new
video he has going okay it's in black
and white cuz my phone's in excited I
think this could be very for our society
so this is the new what do you what do
you think about what do you think about
well for a start he's what he's doing
there yeah okay um so you're boosting
that video in the ALG watching I know
well for a start he's recreating a very
very famous scene with that shot oh okay
it's kind of like a meme that goes
around is around the internet now I
forget ah I think the girls the original
girl's name was Piper Perry very very
tiny tiny little blonde girl mhm um and
she's sitting in the middle of a couch
and there's like five like black actors
behind her I'm actually friends with two
of the guys who were who were in that
shoot oh wow don't know I don't know any
other guys in that though but so that's
what he's doing for a start he's kind of
recreated that exact scene so I think
he's very Adam 22 from what cuz I saw
the stuff that was happening before with
like the Jason love thing and that this
guy ain't an idiot yeah he's this guy's
a marketer right like I'm not I'm I you
cannot convince me that that he does not
know what he's doing yeah when it comes
to like going viral like that because he
knows that a whole bunch of people like
you for example are going to engage with
it I will you will you will I will yes I
will so he knows it's going to get the
get engagement because like there's no
such thing is bad publicity right like
correct cuz he's who's his audience his
audience ain't you know like like
friends like not not friends of mine
like followers of mine yeah his audience
ain't followers of mine who are like you
know trying to go down a
self-improvement route and try to um you
know improve their sex lives improve
their relationship Dynamics that's not
his customer right so if that person
gets angry about his content and Signal
boosts it he wins Happy Days he's good
he's pleased with that his audience the
guys he's going after are the dudes who
would like to watch that material right
you know so it's it's he's a very good
marketer so what do you think about
couples that do only fans together yeah
I mean to me like I used to be in the I
used to kind of I used to kind of
participate in in in that kind of stuff
yeah but you didn't have like a item
that I don't think you had a wife dat I
dated I dated a few girls in the
industry during during my time um a big
part of that to be fair was networking
ability like if you're if you're the
boyfriend of like a star she will
recommend you to like every director and
you'll get more work so to a large
degree that is like a business
relationship but um I know lots of
couples still friends with a bunch of
couples who do that who still create
like of stuff or or their couples their
two couples whatever and they they're on
set every day shooting with other people
ah
it's not for everyone that's for damnn
sure sure as hell not for everyone and
you think they can make it work they do
to this to this day they're still
together the one all the ones I know are
still doing fine really how long has it
been that they're together for It's a
combination of a few different things I
mean there's one one couple that comes
to mind right now they've probably been
together for at least at least four
years at least four years Oh I thought
you're going to say like 10 or something
I didn't I I've only I only met them
like four or five years ago so it's
that's that's that's one example of
they're actually both Stars there's
another couple I know where she's a and
he's just a regular Joe they've been
together they've been married for like
oh [__] at least 8 years okay at least a
years the go on strong seems happy okay
but I don't know what's going on behind
closed doors I don't know I don't know
how genuinely happy he is I don't know
how genuinely happy she is but a lot of
that seems to be like if I could kind of
encapsulate both those examples the one
it's it leaks on the woman side her
getting certain needs met from one guy
and other needs met from a bunch of
dudes so like not to say that the her
husband isn't [__] her right but like
she's definitely getting like a lot of
her sexual F fantasy needs met obviously
from from her line of work and what
she's doing and the the partner is
purely there for like the emotional
connection side of things yeah and so
they they have the ability to this is
the common trait with like stars and and
only fans girls who will shoot like guy
girl porn is their ability to kind of
separate emotion and sex in very much
the same way a guy canh that's because
you couldn't do the job if you didn't it
would be they would they would fall in
love with every guy they had a scene
with right or they'd get burnt out
really quickly which does happen you do
see that and those girls get out of the
industry very quickly they don't last
very long um the turnover rate is is
super fast especially in like Europe but
uh yeah it's it's it's a very special
kind of woman who even has the ability a
unique type of woman who has the ability
to even do that in the first place do
you think it's possible for women you
think it's possible for women to
actually separate the
two not the average woman but these
women seem to do it yeah do do you think
they're born like that or do you think
it's developed over time
I about like where that comes from right
cuz okay oxytocin let's talk about
oxytocin oxytocin is a very very
important chemical
um I've heard I hear this argument all
the time on on places like Twitter for
example that the female orgasm isn't
important because you don't need it to
reproduce babies which is true however
there is another really important reason
for the female orgasm and that is a
thing called oxytocin when a woman has
an orgasm and and there's other things
that cause this to happen but when a
woman has an orgasm as well she gets a
dump of oxytocin in her brain which is
what will trigger that pair bonding
between the partner right the more
sexual partners a woman has had
typically she produces less oxytocin
right with each additional guy so it's a
consequence of like the lack of peir
bond is a consequence I think of just
sleeping around a lot yeah and then it's
a developed ability to separate like sex
and emotion like that yeah that's what I
thought too cuz most of the girls I know
that like kind of went crazy when they
were older I'm like they didn't like if
I knew them from like young you know
like most I don't know anyone that's
done like only fans or anything like
that but like I do know a girl a couple
girls that kind of went off the rails
from like where I'm from and they didn't
start off like that yeah it was
something that seemed to kind of happen
later yep yeah there's a lot of there
also a lot of girls like a lot of the
mil performers like the older girls that
get into the industry and they get into
the industry in their like 30s yeah a
lot of them actually tend to have come
from like a swingers background a that's
very very common like they they were
they've been with like their husband for
like long time the couple the pair of
them decided to experiment and get into
the swinger scene M which is which is
very often the dude's idea really very
often the dude's
idea here's why it's the dude's idea
because he thinks oh this is a free meal
ticket to more
[__] oh but he doesn't realize oh it's
way hard even in the swinger scene it's
way harder way less likely for him to
get a new chick and it's infinitely easy
for his wife to get another dude right
so so he thinks he's going to be the one
sleeping around but generally it's her
yeah oh so it's not really wow yeah what
do you think about those po stars that
are women like Lana rhods um Mia Khalifa
that come back later and say they were
coerced into it the coion is is a load
of [__] okay to be to be frank
like this this whole idea in general
because there a big misconception about
the at least I'll clarify the
professional industry so like this is
prior like only fans that kind of
blurred and muddied the waters here a
lot yeah but prior because only fans
only been around for like five years MH
so prior to that you like you had
professional which was basically like
shooting for any of these big studios
you might have you might find on like
tube sites
right that is an incred professional
industry like loads of like consent
forms model releases paperwork it's all
professional all done above board right
you do you do not get into that industry
by being coerced right like that every
agent I know in La they don't have to
recruit they are inundated with
applications from women all the agents
wow they they have to call they have to
go through their inbox every day and be
like no no no she's cute enough no no no
she's got the right attitude no no no no
like there's not they're not out there
like in the Seedy underbelly of like the
human trafficking area trying to recruit
girls this is I'm talking mainstream
porn this that is not the case but that
gets conflated a lot because there was a
lot of there was a lot of how do I say
this without you getting flagged um
cab let's just say abuse material oh
okay okay on websites like porub okay
and they were profiting off of it they
were making ad Revenue off of it okay it
wasn't getting taken down that stuff is
100% like based around like human
trafficking and stuff yeah but because
it's on the same website as like all the
professional stuff it kind of gets
completed together so when a when a
woman like you know L RADS or Mia C says
like I was coerced into doing this well
you had to like sign a consent form you
had to sign paperwork you had to accept
the job you had to you had to like
contact the agent to like get work in
the first place like where's the
coercion like where's the it's up until
like the whole way through it's like
like you making a choice you making a
choice you're making a choice you're
making a choice where's the where's the
coercion come into it I'm confused yeah
right um so that's that's kind of why
that's my feeling on it too cuz I'm like
how the hell do you get coerced into
doing like that's my question I'm like
could you just say no like no thank you
well yeah professional stuff it's 100%
like you can you can literally like we
have a thing in the industry called a no
list as well right so like you could
like in it's Secret
No One Like Only your agent knows your
no list so I can have I have a list of
girls that I would not I would I refuse
to shoot with I had directors and
companies I refuse to shoot with I had
types of scenes I would refuse to do
yeah and every guy in girl in the
industry has that and your agent
respects that and he doesn't book you
work that violates your no list like
it's super clear well and they always
start an only fans later I'm like what
the Yeah that's they go on they'll go on
like a ho apology tour and then started
only fans after I'm like I thought you
were sorry and and still use their stage
name oh yeah that's so true because it's
search engine optimized wow it's like
what it does but here's the thing here's
so I'm not trying to sh I'm actually
same with the adam22 thing I ain't
trying to [__] on L roads and M cleia
because again these two women are
brilliant marketers yeah especially like
so MIA MIA has been doing this longer
Lana's just jumped on the train but for
the like I don't know how long M's been
doing this for at least four years every
every like 12 months what she would do
is she would she would come out publicly
and [__] on the industry and on Twitter
right and every girl who was currently
in would retweet that [__] in Outrage
and guess what would happen more
eyeballs on Mia Khalifa right she is not
an idiot she is a very very good
marketer same with and Lana's doing the
same thing but like Lana was at the top
of the game she was one of the most
popular like most highly paid talent in
the industry yeah even you know just
before she she left but both of them
have fans and counts both of them are
making money off of it so every time you
you can you like buy into this like out
this rage bait just realize you're like
as angry as you are at it you you're
you're putting money in the bank account
see I don't really think that they're
these smart marketers I really don't or
maybe boyfriend is I'll give Adam 22 I
do think Adam I mean I don't think he
can make that scene I I just think the
women kind of go through a cycle and
it's like they're like oh I don't want
the consequence and then they're here
and then they're trying to get rid of it
then they realize oh
it doesn't really matter I'm going to
have this consequence anyway yeah here
let me start my only fans I I just I
just I don't believe it's that well
thought out personally like I'm not
gonna I'm not going to call Lana rhods a
brilliant marketer I can't I can't I'm
sorry I'll give it Adam 22 I'll give it
too that man runs a whole production
company but I don't know i' you'd be
you'd be surprised how smart a lot of
these girls are by
St um what do you think about Born Again
virgins are you a born again virgin now
I'm definitely not a born again virgin
you're not you can't you can't be a born
again
virgin that just yeah not possible not
possible you can't you can't regain your
vCard oh no but so what made you leave
the poor industry though very good
question um it was largely a frustration
of not being able to speak my mind okay
in case you can't tell I'm I'm a lot
more right leaning
okay in like my beliefs and and my
opinions politically and like socially
and the entire is like all leftwing
really based out of California it's all
like
okay it all very much resonates with
that whole like um agenda propaganda
whatever you want to call it so like
there was there was lots of instances of
of I'd be on this is actually perfect
example because it was during like the
Trump era right I'd be on set and I was
very Pro Trump at the time uh until the
back stuff happened and I'm like this
guy's [__] up yeah but basically um
you'd be on set and you and like my
co-star would be would be super
feminist all the women are feminists by
the way which might sound ironic but
they are all 100% feminists And they all
they all say they're feminists well not
100% well that makes sense it's
egalitarianism we can do what men can do
okay that does make sense that's a good
way of explaining it yes and so uh you
know they they come on they' be they'd
be bitching and winging about Trump or
something and in back of my head I'm
like [__] yes nice one like
he nailed it there and I can't say [__]
you're right so but would you be
blacklisted or something 100% I would I
would have not got work instantly okay
instantly have you said anything
anything really 100% okay and the moment
I decided I'm getting out of this
industry I actually went I went on and
tweeted some like red pill stuff and the
very next day I was canceled bam gone
like no more work agent called me up
like what the [__] what are you doing
what did you tweet wasn't even that big
of a deal I tweeted the big one that got
me like Mega canceled was if she calls
herself a queen a princess a brat or a
bad [__] she's probably not
relationship material okay I mean that's
basic yeah yes thank yes that's pretty
that's pretty like basically basically
don't date a narcissist yeah that's what
I was about to say it's narcissism yeah
but literally like almost every girl in
the industry will kind of lab will use
one of those labels to to Define themsel
okay literally be in their Twitter bio
so I was kind of being a bit cheeky I
knew I knew that would ruffle up some
feathers but but I went cuz I was in I
was actually in Spain no Portugal at the
time when I tweeted it went to bed it
the Americans saw it and I woke up the
next morning to about 900 Twitter
notifications wow it just it just
exploded around the industry and
everyone was like cancel this guy cancel
this guy cancel this guy like [__] just
trying to [__] on my reputation and
stuff like yeah and but it was kind of
like it was it was good because I I was
kind of
like had like one foot still in it yeah
a little bit and that was all I need
like that was the like ah this is this
is what like you wanted you wanted free
speech Sterling here's your free speech
go did you get like a call from your
manager yeah yeah and did he say you're
basically [__] out of work yeah okay
yeah and then you just kept going I'm
that yeah yeah make I built I built a
business off what I know how to teach
yeah and I'm I'm I'm a quite quite a
good teacher and I have a I actually
have a scientific background as well
okay so like I'm able to pull on a whole
bunch of resources and I'm like you know
what this going to be a challenge but
I'll make it work and I have I'm very
happy with it do you think porn is a net
good or net negative net negative easily
easily a net negative is that weird
having that opinion being that how long
did you do for five five years five
years is it weird having that opinion
having done it yeah it's a bit weird
because it's I look at the way I look at
it now is like I don't I can't I can't
regret having done it because if I
hadn't have done it I wouldn't have been
in a position to like have learned a
bunch of stuff okay to help guys like
bioh hacks and things like that that I'd
learned from like old the veterans of
the game like what like what to eat what
supplements to take like how to exercise
all this other stuff I had to learn in
order to be able to teach it to the
average guy to help his sex life so I
can't I can't regret it like that but I
just the way I look at it now is like
I'm just trying to make up for like the
damage I did okay because it's not it's
not like the the only context I you
might be able to argue that like kind of
good is to SP like for couples to watch
to kind of like spice things up a bit
again M and they were like watching it
together and like kind of creating a
fantasy and just and redirecting that
sexual energy into their relationship
you could make an argument for that but
in general like especially like internet
man like that is horrific it's on every
on every kids's phone like easily
accessible yeah like Po like when I was
growing up it was like I remember we me
and some friends we went down to the tip
like the local garbage dump cuz one of
the kids knew that the local news agency
had dumped a bunch of nudie mags
somewhere in the tip yeah and we went
around like half a day scaming it and we
eventually found like a pile of like
this magazine and we all took one and
that was like our masturbation material
as teenagers for about six years right
whereas now it's like the average guy
today has seen more naked women than
like genas Khan would have seen in his
lifetime right which is ridiculous the
human the male brain isn't really made
for that level of sexual exposure I
don't think it's it's it's a dangerous
thing we're playing with well and even
like I I have this argument okay I'm
curious your your take what comes first
women asking for sexual attention from
men or men asking for sex I would argue
that women ask for sexual attention
first my reason being is I was in Vegas
and these chicks are walking like they
have stickers on their boobs I'm like
well it's it's it's women asking for
attention in general and because men
view women as sexual objects any
attention is ero associated with sex do
you think women are just as sexual as
men yes but they do they defer their
responsibility onto men could you
explain that more like they they will
never take they can't take
responsibility for it and they can't
really the average woman cannot really
initiate it like they still have just as
many sexual fantasies and if and in a
lot of cases women's sexual fantasies
are more perverted than guys sexual
fantasies a really good book to read is
My Secret Garden by Nancy Friday have
you ever heard this book so nany I think
she was a New York Times journalist I
believe and she basically put an ad in
the New York Times asking for women to
write in their Anonymous sexual
fantasies okay and it's just a
compilation of that is it like very dark
is it like cuz I've heard there was a
male only fans model that came on the
show and he said the number one thing he
gets from women is like rape fantasies
it's along those lines lot a lot of that
stuff a lot of that stuff yeah super
dark and I remember reading that in my
early 20s and that like that changed me
from thinking of women as like sugar and
spice and everything nice like holy crap
women are perverts so it's I think it's
it's good for the average man to
understand that now you could make the
argument that maybe that's just modern
women this book was written in like the
80s so it's still it's not super duper
old right but I do think that uh yeah
women tend to be a lot more sexual but
they're just better at concealing it
maybe well but maybe not so much now
yeah they're walking around with just
stickers on the titties they're not
really concealing it what do you think
because they'll just say not all women
are like that it's just the women that
you know Sterling okay well but my
sample size is like in in EX in excess
of like 600 now oh wow so I'm not that's
I that's not that's literally just
because of I know I I know how many
scenes I did I know how many clients I
did I know right like okay what what's
your sample size how many wom have you
interacted with in your life their wife
no no okay and maybe her friends okay
cool like I'm talk like we can't we
can't talk about generalizations without
taking like yeah I say the same thing
yeah like a big sample size so what do
you teach guy like what are the biggest
problems that guys come to you with cool
well one of the first things I teach
guys going back to your previous point
is to not watch okay very very adamant I
want to make sure that's very very clear
I tell every guy cut that [__] out right
because it can be something that really
drags you back with a lot of these the
these are the problems that guys come to
me with so two of the most common ones
are either erectile dysfunction or
premature ejaculation those the two very
very common ones and probably the third
more common one is like how do I
generally how do I get my woman off like
how do I get get it an orgasm in this
position or that position or like some
kind of a more technical
mechanical kind of a question like that
okay yeah those are those probably the
big three okay um why do you tell them
not to watch por well a couple of really
good reasons um one from a brain
chemistry perspective like we mentioned
before like the average guy seen more
titties like a king or a sultan would
have in his entire lifetime what that
does is it screws around with your your
um your dopamine receptors when you're
constantly bombarding it it's the by the
way it's the exact same thing that in
incessantly scrolling on Tik Tok does
exact same thing that incessantly eating
like sugary foods does it basically just
destroys eating sugary Foods has the
same effect as por well it has an effect
on your dopamine receptors right it's
it's it's a spike it's just like right
people use sugary Foods or you know uh
what you would call like Comfort Foods
right they use it to like what what they
what's the comfort from the comfort from
anxiety they're trying to like get some
kind of a dopamine release sugary Foods
tend to do that more than like veggies
right yeah yeah fair enough not not to
the maybe not to the same extent mm but
uh yeah the idea is you're constantly
bombarding your brain with dopamine The
receptors become less like it causes
less of an effect on the it takes a
bigger dose shall we say a bigger
stimulus to cause a same effect so the
guy who you know might have been able to
like jerk off
to a glimpse of a woman's ankle at one
point now he he has to go through like
50 odd videos to finally get his so
that's that's one of the big reasons it
it dampens his dopamine receptors which
which again leads to a whole bunch of
other things like it leads to reduce
motivation reduce drive from a guy uh
reduces his ability to uh climax reduces
his ability to get excited and aroused
in front of a real woman because a real
woman in front of him is not as novel
and stimulating to his brain as the 50
different women he saw last night when
he was jacking it mhm right so it's one
of the first things dudes need to like
cut out if they got if they have any
problem whatsoever in the bedroom the
first thing they should be doing is
cutting that
out what can men do to maintain
attraction in their
relationships be aware of the masculine
and feminine polarity and being aware of
like like emphasizing your masculine
polarity so what I mean by that
is women want to feel feminine women
want to be in that more let's say
submissive role in the bedroom and and I
would say outside the bedroom I think
the bedroom's like a microcosm for what
goes on outside the relationship like
I've had guys for example who I've
taught how to be a bit more of a
dominant passionate lover and then they
Le me back like a month later and be
like oh she's she's cooking and cleaning
again she's not she's not nagging about
taking the trash out really so you think
that what happens in the bedroom is like
kind of a symbol almost for what's going
on in the relationship or it reflect
refs it yeah it reflects it it's well
the outside reflects the in the the
inside the bedroom so like if the
relationship dynamic in the bedroom is
like polarized like that she's going to
feel like he's an actual man when she
like let's give another
example if she is the one who has to
like lead sex if he's constantly
like begging for her to initiate sex
taking like the supplicative role she's
not going to respect that man mhm she's
not going to get aroused by that man and
then okay when when they're outside the
bedroom that's when she start she's
going to start nagging him take out of
the trash that's what she she going to
start emasculating him in front of his
friends and disrespect disrespecting in
public so you almost think all of the
relationship problems go back to sex not
I wouldn't say all of them but I'd say
that I'd say it is always a factor wow
I'd say it's it's it runs parallel right
with a lot of stuff and that's why I
think it's a very easy way to fix it
because men are still allowed to be men
in the bedroom mhm right it's a bit like
if you were out if you were out in
public
and like a man was trying to say let's
let's say trying to keep this woman in
line or something like you're showing
too much shoulder let's just say that
example he's saying that out loud in
public You Know cover up your ankles
yeah
right Society every everybody around him
is going to like look at him very
negatively for being that for taking
that role and taking that stance but in
the privacy of the bedroom
he can take the leadership role take the
more masculine role be more passionate
be more dominant in that regard
obviously consensually we're not saying
anything's not consensual yeah but he's
allowed to do that there because that's
their intimate relationship the two of
them it's a consensual thing between the
two of them no one's interfering with it
so now we can start to repair if if the
dynamic was off we can start to kind of
fix it by just tapping getting her back
into her feminine getting her back into
that submissive mindset where she can
look up to a man and respect him and
think oh this is this is why I fell in
love with this guy this is why I I I
started going like started dating this
guy cuz he's the [__] man right he
gets me off he arouses me he gets me wet
between the legs like she can't have
those if she doesn't have those feelings
at all for a man that's it's going to
lead to a dead bedroom it's going to
lead to resentment it's going to lead to
nagging it's going to lead to all kinds
of other problems manifesting outside of
it right so in a in a large way I think
you would be quite the average couple
would be very very surprised how much
they can fix how many problems you you
don't need to go to a therapist right
you just need to learn how to Dick her
down properly and like like a lay the
pipe oh magically she's happy again yeah
I it really
it okay another example I'll give you is
like not just me but also friends of
mine we'll you know we'll take a girl
out on a date who's a feminist mhm and
after we're done like if we if we sleep
with her once or twice okay now she's
cooking and cleaning around the house
she's not a feminist anymore yeah like
it's a stuff I've seen that on the show
like girls like will fight with a guy
the whole show and then they'll hit on
him after
yeah it's like and most but most guys
have never had that experience in their
life or they've never seen anyone else
do it so it sounds like we're in talking
in the Realms of fantasy yeah but we're
really not this is this is well within
every guy's like capability have you
ever had a guy that was in a super
disrespectful like maybe she was leading
relationship and you actually got him to
turn it around because I've heard like
two schools of thought I've heard one
school of thought that if a relationship
starts that way or it's gotten to that
point you just need to start over like
there's no fixing it um and then you
know I've heard people say that you can
maybe turn it around so what's your that
I would the first thing I'd probably ask
the guy is like okay are are you are you
married and are there kids
involved because if there's kids
involved and they're married and stuff
it's like look do I'm not going to tell
the guy to like end the marriage yeah
I'm gonna say look this is going to suck
and it's not going to happen overnight
it's going to take a while but okay
maybe we should start with these little
things in a bedroom little just not not
going all full out but like little stuff
and then we'll see over time maybe we
can start to steal this better in the
right direction I have had at least one
guy who's kind from like a long long
term relationship has managed to adjust
the dynamic he had but typically if a
guys if it's not there's not kids
involved and they're not married and
stuff like that I'll just say make just
leave her get a new girl yeah cuz like
this ain't like if you have kids and
kids with this woman or get married with
this woman now it ain't going to fix it
it ain't going to get better that that
it's going to get way worse cuz now
she's got all this power over you right
like yeah it's always easier to kind of
start from something new but you know we
start start with the start with a found
a solid foundation yeah right yeah I
think and that's I mean a bunch of the
guys who follow consume consume my my
YouTube material whatever they they're
single guy and so I think I by having
them understand like you know this idea
of like a masculine and feminine
polarity for example they're going to at
least start relationships a bit better
off than a guy who's ignorant of that so
um one criticism that I hear a lot
is from the conservative crowd a bit
more that red pill guys just tell the
men to sleep around um you know for
example I think myON says You must sleep
with 50 women before you settle down do
you agree with that you know what in in
it's kind of weird CU I kind of AG I I I
agree with what he said because it's
like I wouldn't have the knowledge I
have if I hadn't have slept with as many
women as I had yeah I wouldn't have the
dynamic understanding however does the
average guy need to do
that not really like you can like I know
guys who picked this stuff up quicker
than I did with far lower like the dude
has a lower body count but they they got
it quicker mhm so consuming stuff like
like fresh and fit like you like me you
know all these people are trying to help
guys can help them to understand like
the Dynamics between men and women so
they like you said before they don't
start the relationship off badly I would
love it if every guy could do like one
andone and it's a great relationship I
would love that I would genuinely love
that and they make make everyone really
happy MH do I think it's realistic no I
don't think it's that that realistic
yeah and I
think there is an there is an abundance
of sh we're probably going to get into
this bit later tonight but there's an
abundance of women who are maybe like
past their prime or who are just all
these women want from their life is to
just sleep around and have a bit of fun
mhm okay well they these are a let's say
good training wheels for a guy who was
just trying to understand women a bit
better so that when he does find a woman
who meets all of his criteria and
standards a woman he can take seriously
and settle down with he's not going into
that relationship blind like he's not
going into it completely unaware of the
kind of manipulation tactics that women
can use on him I think that's a bit
better now you you can find guys and i'
I've met a couple of guys who are like
actual virgins who have all this [__]
down pat already if I could figure out a
way to replicate that that that's like a
amazing thing because like but I mean
look at look at St for example right
married his wife as a virgin and he he's
one he's one such guy I would have said
I would have said in the past I think
he's actually he actually understands a
lot of the stuff we talk about
but evidently not quite so yeah and that
was really unfortunate because they all
labeled him as an AB like it it was
rough yeah that was rough um so you've
said in the past men should be able to
control their emotions women should be
feminine and men should be masculine
yeah
why I know I happier that way I want an
emotionally available guy know no you
don't you don't you don't want an
emotionally erratic guy yeah like you
can have a like a guy can have emotions
but he's in control of them that's what
stoicism is yeah like you don't not feel
emotions that would make you like a
sociopath right and that's what I'm not
saying I'm not saying guys should be
Psychopathic or sociopathic guys can
have an emotion but think this is a way
I was taught to think about at a young
age every you have is a choice mhm
because you get external stimulus from
the world it passes through like a
filter and then your brain decides how
to interpret that M so like I don't know
let's say some guy cuts me off in
traffic right external stimulus has now
hit my brain I there's a there's a
moment there where I have I can make a
decision about how I'm going to react to
it I can choose to get pissed off and
assume he's being a [__] or I can
choose to not get pissed off make sure I
don't crash my car and and think well
maybe this guy's on his way to the
hospital is maybe he's got a pregnant
wife in the in the passenger seat and
he's in a rush yeah I don't know but
there's a there's a choice there but
before every emotion you feel you have a
choice whether to feel it or not so
being being in control of your emotions
rather than having your emotions control
you is I think very healthy for men very
healthy for society very healthy for
relationships and the opposite of a dude
who's super erratic uh no impulse
control what does that lead to least to
that least to violence at leasts to
Crime that least to like all all kinds
of problems yeah I even think women can
learn from that too like because I think
a lot of times especially like in
relationships sometimes something
happens or we get mad over things that
are small and we think it's like bigger
than it is yeah and I I always think
like by giving people the benefit of the
doubt it's like I don't know yeah some
people will take advantage of it but I
think in general most people are good
they want to do the right thing yeah and
people just have bad days yeah yeah
having a bad day I've had shitty days in
the past like been a complete dick to my
to like friends and employees and and
and girlfriends and stuff before but
it's like that's not I'm not that way
all the time just had a bad day yeah you
know and like I think that most people
are generally good people good at heart
or they think they're doing they think
they're at least doing good they might
be a bit delusional about the way the
world works yeah so they're just doing
that they're just doing what they know
is best MH how did you get connected to
the hates through Twitter of all things
okay yeah we me and Tristan started
talking on Twitter had uh Tristan on my
my YouTube channel interviewed him while
back and then me and Andrew start out
chatting and then I met up with them in
Vegas uh they were put on an event in
Vegas in 2021 they invited me along that
same night I met I met them I also met
Justin Waller yeah um a few other guys
who I'm still friends with to this day
in this one sort of event really really
really cool night and then yeah we hung
out in a bunch of different countries
together
had had a bunch of fun times and uh yeah
are you in the war room I am okay so
what what is that it's a business
Network an international business
Network for guys uh not just not just
business though primarily it's it's a
better way of saying is like it's a
Brotherhood Network really kind of like
the the emphasis of it is like
Adventures of Excellence with like a
community of Brothers yeah it's like
doing really cool [__] with guys you
share a common worldview with right and
that's that's kind of how me and Justin
met yeah that's what we've been doing
for the last last couple years going on
going on crazy adventures together and
having a great time that's kind of what
the War Room really tries to facilitate
is a place where men can be men men can
like find other guys who they get along
with who who share Hobbies like be that
racing cars be that uh you know Firearms
be that dog training uh like hiking like
like anything you can possibly imagine
their like business obviously like
Social Media stuff like uh trading
crypto like real estate anything you
could think of there's like different
kind of uh groups within that group
where these guys can share these ideas
and it's super useful man like I If I
have a problem with anything right if I
want to learn something really quickly
like I have a question about real estate
I have a question about like stocks or
something I could just drop a message
and an expert in that field will be able
to answer me like instantly it's
ridiculous what has it been like
watching your friend um get cancelled
thrown in jail have all these baseless
accusations at them sucks yeah it sucks
for them um and it's
it's it sucks to see like some two guys
you genuinely care about you know who
who you know are some of the most
generous people on the planet they they
people don't really understand how
lovely these two guys are behind closed
doors cuz all they see is like the
internet kind of persona and they and
what people push out and retweet and and
what goes viral right but when you
actually get to spend time random
one-on-one like cameras off like it's
just guys shooting the [__] they're
amazing dudes lovely dudes not to say
that they aren't on social media either
but it it really shows you
like how impactful Andrew is because
they want to shut him up right like he's
been almost locked up for a year
now there's no they're not going to put
him in jail like they would have by now
like they're not going to put him in
jail and it's clearly just them trying
to silence him they're trying to make
Andrew irrelevant that's what they're
trying to do like if we just okay if we
put him away in jail for long enough if
we put him in on house for us long
enough we just keep him in Romania for
long enough if we take away his cars he
can't go out and flex and be seen if we
you know limit like his social media
accounts like he can't influence people
like that's going to reduce his effect
on the world but they've just turned
Andrew into a mder right like his he's
one of the few people who's gone more
viral after it got canceled yeah
probably the only one I can think of
yeah I don't know anyone that's been
taken off all platforms and is more
wellknown right yeah so the they're
playing completely backfired yeah how
are they doing yeah they're fine yeah
like these these two guys are really
hard to like you can't you can't like
screw with these two guys yeah like they
are especially like together they are
the strongest pair of men I have ever
met like not just physically but
mentally these guys you can't break them
so and they and they've got each other
they having a they they love each
other's company they love like they love
living aromania for a start they love
Bucharest yeah like they've got they got
their family their family safe most
importantly so yeah they're doing fine
but it's the day can't come soon enough
when these guys actually get get
released for God's sake do you think
it's important for men to have a group
of men around them absolutely yeah it's
something I I was missing it completely
really I didn't realize I didn't realize
until I like joined the war room and and
met a bunch of guys in there and found
guys that I resonated with it was for me
it was kind of like prior to that prior
to like joining the war room I there was
probably like one maybe two guys in my
whole life who I'd basically who had
stuck by me my whole life and we'd very
much gone on the same journey and shared
a similar worldview and then I joined
the war and I was like oh this is where
everybody is oh this is where all these
guys are they're all here that's
surprising to me that you didn't have a
ton of like guy friends before like I
had I had guy friends from like
University and stuff but then I left
Australia came to America you moved
around yeah I bounced around a lot and
it's the guy that I stayed in touch with
were the ones that I would i' say to
this day are like my closest friends
right but then I made a whole bunch more
super super close friends one of the
reasons I moved out to Maya like bunch
of guys out there who I really resonate
together and it's it's just it's just
nice like the average guy was probably
very lonely yeah the average guy
actually especially the average like
entrepreneurial guy yeah cuz being an
entrepreneur you know this like it's
it's it's a very like lonely kind of
experience lonely kind of Journey right
you've got to like you're taking a lot
of responsibility on yourself like
sometimes like your team members don't
necessarily know why you've chose a
certain direction or not yeah um yeah
and the average person who's working
like a 9 to5 can't necessarily really
relate to you and what you're doing so
it could be a kind of isolating
experience so when you surround yourself
with other dudes who are doing that kind
of same thing it's really refreshing
yeah very nice experience so where can
the people that want to find you where
can they find
you can go to uh YouTube and you can
type in stering Cooper I'm the first and
it comes up uh F which is great stilling
cooper.com another great place to go
find like all of the things I have to
offer you guys all the solutions I offer
guys uh yeah like my books and my video
courses Etc or you can just get on my
free email list I've got a free ebook
which put you on my free email list and
you can listen to all my various musics
on masculinity on Health on Fitness I I
just dump a ton of stuff on on guys
every day in the inbox so you have a
course coming out soon don't you I have
well I actually have a supplement line
oh supplement line supplement line
coming out right now um I've been like I
said before I've got my background is
chemistry MH I was actually a published
scientific author before I even
graduated oh wow odly enough yeah most
don't know that um and so for the last
12 months I basically been formulating
effectively like what a supplement based
around what I used to take every day
before I would go shoot a scene okay in
order to make sure I was like ready to
rock and roll yeah consistently like on
on command so that's something I've been
working on for the last 12 months I've
finally found a really good American
manufacturer to crank it out very very
happy with it and uh yeah that's it's
cool if you go to clubhous
supplements.com that's where you'll find
that stuff and is that does that help
with like the testosterone because isn't
I would imagine that's part of the
erectile stuff is like PE the the lack
of testosterone no it can contribute to
it oh wow the main the main reasons
behind a rectile dysfunction is about
three the three key mechanisms of them
one is a problem with like the arteries
themselves so people you know people
think of like cardiovascular health
right you can get arterial plaes and
things like that people think of it
being associated with just the heart but
your penis has arteries too and they can
also get those same kind of arterial
plaques and thus it can limit the blood
flow down there that's the first thing
that we want to work on getting rid of
and kind of cleaning out second thing is
like blood flow itself Nitric which is
based around nitric oxide production so
nitric oxide when when dudes go to the
gym they get they get a pump right
that's nitric oxide causing their blood
vessels to expand and relax the the
erection is actually a relaxation
response people don't really think of it
that way but it is you get nitric oxide
dilates your blood vessels they fill
with with more blood andless things get
bigger and the third problem that that
tends to happen is a thing called Venus
leakage so if you have ever seen someone
with varicose veins before those like
kind of spidery veins that go on the leg
or whatever that's a problem with what's
called Venus leakage which is basically
there there's kind of like these locks
in your arteries which help the blood
only flow in like One Direction mhm when
those like locks kind of get weak the
blood can kind of move back and forth it
can move backwards as much as moving in
forwards and it kind of just sits there
pools on the surface rather than moving
like in the direction it's supposed to
so when you fix that and you you you get
you supplement with things that can
actually maintain the health of those
valves M you keep everything like locked
in the place you want it to be locked in
all the blood stays into one spot okay
much longer okay and so that the
supplement like helps with that
basically I formul all the ingredients
in the supplement are specifically
engineered towards that wow yeah very
cool yeah that's that's what I've been
working on for like 12 months well thank
you very much for coming on today thank
you po guys U make sure you go subscribe
to his channel um like the video on your
way out and also guys get yourself a
women shouldn't vote t-shirt today you
know all of the world's problems I'm
going to get they're not delivered yet
but I'll get Sterling one
too get yourself a t-shirt you're going
to be the ultimate alpha male the women
will just come up to left and right and
just say how awesome and amazing you are
definitely going guaranteed guaranteed
or your money back um get it um the link
is in the description and I'll talk to
you next time